what's up guys welcome back to my series
on web scraping with r
in the last video we web scraped this
imdb page now if we actually open up the
data frame
we can see that we got the names the
years the ratings and the synopses of
each of these movies
and in this video we're going to
actually build off of that so if you
haven't watched that video i'd recommend
checking that out and then coming back
and watching this one
but essentially we're going to go more
into our vests and web scraping
we're going to go into nested links
which is when you
scrape links and then navigate to those
links scrape even more data from the
links
essentially i want to add another column
to this data frame of all the
primary cast members for each of these
movies now you can see some of the stars
right here that are listed but
i think it's only like four of them for
each movie and i want
a lot more i want all the primary ones
and those are only listed
if we go into the movie and then come
down to cast
they're down here so going back to our
code
we actually don't have to add a whole
lot the first step is going to be
actually grabbing the urls for each of
these movies
now we wrote the code for it so
or at least most of the code for it so
it's not too hard we just need to add
a new variable called movie links and
uh you see name if we run this part
we get this title tt and then back to
the future if we go into one of these
movies you can see
the url is actually imdb.com title blah
blah blah
so the links are there we just need to
somehow put it all together
so once we've copied the html nodes
up to that part we can paste that for
movie links
and now instead of grabbing the text we
want to grab this actual value here
inside of the the a tag so
we're going to call this function called
html attr
and then we're going to pass in href and
this will grab this value
now again we're not fully there yet
because if we run that that gives us
the value we're looking for but we
obviously can go to this link
so we need to pass in one more or sorry
call one more function and that's gonna
be paste
and paste is gonna concatenate strings
together so we need to concatenate the
imdb.com website that url with
the end of this so let me just get rid
of
the extra slash so
i just need to add comma and then period
and i mentioned earlier how piping
it takes everything towards the left of
the pipe
it computes that and it passes whatever
that result is
as the first argument to the function
after the pipe
so theoretically if we just had
paste imdb.com it would call
you know one of these titles and then
imdb.com after that but that's not what
we want so we specify
that the whatever is being passed in is
passed as a second argument
by putting that period there and then
the last thing we need
is sep equals empty quotes because by
default
paste will add an empty space between
the two strings we're trying to
concatenate and because these are links
we don't want that
so we can go ahead and run this and just
see what it looks like and that's
exactly what we want so that looks good
now that we have all the movie links we
need to figure out a way to actually go
into each of the pages
and scrape the cast members if you come
from a programming background or have
done any coding at all you might be
tempted to use a for loop here
but i think r is actually more efficient
when it's using supply and l apply
functions
rather than for loops so we're going to
try to do that
and it's not super super hard even
though it is kind of tricky
but first i'm going to get rid of this
right.csv because we no longer need that
and then i'm going to start writing some
code right here
i'm going to create a function that
essentially takes in
one of these movie links and scrapes
these cast members and then just returns
whatever that string is
so we're going to call that get cast
it's going to be a function that takes
in a movie link
and the first thing we need to do kind
of similar to
how we read in this html source code
we're going to need to read in
the movie link and generate our page
and then once we have that page we can
grab the cast
and again this is really similar to all
these other
web scraping functions that we did up
here
so we have the page
we pipe that into html nodes
and now we just need to figure out the
css tag so we'll go to chrome
click on one of these cast members and
now deselect what we don't want
and that's perfect i have a list of
these primary cast members so i'll copy
that tag
put it into our html nodes
and last is just to grab the text
cool so i want to test this function out
or at least what's inside the function
but i don't want to go over every single
movie link
so i'm just going to put a temporary
variable here called movie link that is
going to be the same as this
just so we can test out what this
function does so i'll copy
one of these links right here just as an
example
great and now if i run these three lines
hopefully moviecast should be equal to
exactly what i want which is these cast
members so that looks great
now the only thing here is that because
i want to eventually append
uh this output as a column onto this
movie's data frame
i need to do one other step and that is
calling paste again to collapse all of
these
15 different elements into just one
element
specifically into one string so i'll
call paste with this collapse argument
then that should be good oops
if i run this that gives me just one
element
one string that's perfect now the last
thing is to return
moviecast and then since we know that
all this works now i can get rid of this
temporary moving link variable
cool so now i have movie links
which is equal to all these different
imdb links
and i have this function getcast that's
equal to
a function that given a movie link
scrapes all the cast names and returns a
string a single string with them
so in order to put it all together i'm
going to call the supply function
first we're going to create a new cast
variable so this is going to be the
column
similar to all these other columns that
we're going to add to our data frame
and it's going to take in the movie
links
and function get cast
and essentially the way supply works is
given the
first variable which is a vector of
movie links
it'll go into each one grab this
run it through the function you know
passing it in as a parameter
and then whatever the result is it'll
just put that back into a vector for me
so that should be good to go
the last thing is to add cast
as the fifth column to our data frame
and now if we run all of our code
cool so now if i view movies
you see that we get this last column
with each of the cast members
and of course you can do any kind of
text cleaning i just wanted
all of it flattened into one element and
the last thing is you see all of these
imdb
stuff that it added this is because when
we created cast
using the supply function it left in
all of the the movie urls right there
and if you don't want that you can just
pass in
use dot names equals false
and if you rerun this that should fix it
and it should go back to having no name
here
so that's pretty much it for this video
i definitely recommend checking out the
next part
where we go into dealing with multiple
pages
but if you have any other feedback
definitely let me know in the comments
and thanks for watching
see you the next one